[Music]
here's a story you might not have heard
in 1946 president harry truman created a
commission to make recommendations for
how to reform higher education
after doing extensive research the
commission released a six volume report
arguing that higher education was
becoming increasingly important
and should be accessible to everyone
regardless of age
background or ability to pay as a first
step
the truman commission proposed making
freshman and sophomore year of college
totally free at public universities the
commission also recommended offering
grants to fully cover living expenses
for students who needed them
and it recommended providing all of this
on an inclusive basis
dismantling racial and religious
exclusion increasing women's enrollment
and creating more flexible admission
standards to account for economic
disadvantages
and that was all just supposed to be a
first step how did they propose to pay
for this
the commission found that the phenomenal
increases in productivity per worker
from technology
would generate enough social surplus to
support education at all levels far
more adequately in the future than we
could in the past
that is so long as we made education a
collective priority
and then congress implemented the
commission's recommendations
and college has been affordable to
everybody who wants to attend
ever since okay that last part isn't
true
actually it's just the opposite today
america is drowning in student debt
1.7 trillion dollars of it and growing
it's hard to imagine a presidential
commission making the types of
recommendations that the truman
commission did
even though we live in a much wealthier
more integrated
and more technologically advanced
society what happened
well the truman commission was right
that productivity would continue to
increase
but we did not make education a
collective priority
or more accurately political elites who
are worried that too much education
would lead to too much equality
didn't make it a priority so the growing
wealth created by increased productivity
went toward making the rich richer
and not into educating more people to
see how this happened
we have to go back to the end of the
second world war
that was the first time many middle
class people started to go to college
because of a federal law called the gi
bill veterans a huge percentage of the
population back then
could even attend college for free
because of state-level commitments to
education
public college was cheap and accessible
for massive numbers of people
beyond veterans too there were still
deep inequalities
but college was no longer just a
training ground for the rich
with universities opening to more people
feminists and the civil rights movement
began to break down barriers
the increasing presence of working-class
people women and people of color on
college campuses made them centers for
political and social dissent protests
debate and activism became part of
college life
soon there was a backlash some
politicians thought this was too much
free speech from the wrong type of
people
they wanted a return to the old system a
candidate for california governor named
ronald reagan
started attacking people he called
campus radicals
in the year 1970 an adviser to reagan
declared in a speech
we are in danger of producing an
educated proletariat
that's dynamite we have to be selective
on who we allow to go through higher
education
when these politicians gain power they
made sharp cuts to education funding
california under reagan's influence went
from funding 32 percent of the
university of california budget in 1974
to just 16 in 2004 elsewhere
cuts to education were justified on the
logic of living within our means
president gerald ford criticized new
york city's cuny system for offering a
program where
any high school graduate rich or poor
could attend without paying tuition
imagine that in the midst of a city
budget crisis in 1976
wall street bond investors forced cuny
to charge tuition for the first time
while politicians were slashing funding
business strategies to undermine
working-class power restructured
industry in a way that redirected income
toward jobs and management and finance
and away from everyone else the jobs
that paid well required college degrees
and that meant that even as education
funding collapsed
the number of people entering college
continued to increase
so incomes for most people were starting
to stagnate
and higher education was becoming more
important and getting a job that paid
well
so more and more people were going to
college meanwhile because of an ideology
of false scarcity
state funding was not keeping up what
filled the gap
student loans student loans
are actually a creation of the federal
government they were created on the
assumption
that states would mostly cover the cost
of college so federal loans would be for
a relatively small number of people
paid off painlessly within a few years
of graduating but
as tuition climb and state grants
receded
a whole industry developed around
student lending
by the 1990s massive student loans were
the norm
and colleges began to base their
business models around them fast forward
to today
and the results have been catastrophic
45 million americans have student loans
and each graduating class owes more than
the last
in 1980 there were only a few million
dollars of student loans
by 2000 that number was around 50
billion
in 2010 200 billion and today we have
nearly
2 trillion dollars outstanding instead
of starting a family
or buying a car let alone starting a
business or starting a movement
young people today live with a sort of
debt hanging over their head
student debt is even causing many older
people to put off retirement
things are so bad that 1 in 15 student
borrowers
has considered suicide because of it too
many lives
are being ruined and here is the
craziest part
all of that student debt doesn't have to
exist
i'm not saying that in a hypothetical
way i'm saying that if the president of
the united states wanted
he could wipe out almost all student
debt right now
you see 95 percent of student debt is
owed to the federal department of
education
and when congress created the student
loan program it gave the secretary of
education
authority to compromise waive or release
or modify
any federal student loan debt for any
reason this is often called settlement
authority now
the settlement authority has never been
used to bring about broad cancellation
but
i've done a deep review of the relevant
case law and the legal argument for it
is very strong
in fact after i wrote a law review
article that made the case
a growing number of senators have been
convinced and began to advocate for the
department of education
to cancel student debt few things are
certain in law
but clearly the case is good enough that
it's at least worth a test
think about it canceling federal student
loans would instantly make tens of
millions of people's lives better
its benefits would flow to their
families and their communities
and help stimulate the broader economy
but canceling student loan debt
is only the first step toward building a
higher education system that works for
all
if we care about living in a democratic
society we should use our enormous
wealth
to invest in making it possible for
anyone to access
all the education they want certainly we
should not condemn people to a lifetime
of debt for wanting to learn or better
themselves
all of this was clear to a presidential
commission in 1946
it's well past time to recover that
vision and to build on it
i'm luke herron phd student at yale law
school
for the gravel institute
[Music]
you